[Applaudissements]
la madone
bonsoir alors salut salut
philippe lucas aurait donc mon frangin
hervé lucas salut la compagnie vraiment
troisième frère di luca qui fait vieux
dames camille lacourt qu'on connaît bien
qu'elle est sans fond acapela up
philippe lucas a cappella bilic ap la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
haye pas venu pour poser de la moquette
croyez moi donc qu'est-ce qui doit
trouver à tabac excuse moi si tu n'as
pas pieds tu vas pas dans le grand
bassin
c'était écrit ça donc ça fait deux ans
qu'on est d'accord on est promise et
c'est bien ce que je pense c'est plein
fouet alors alors tu expliques on chante
des chansons des missions qu'on sort des
émissions télé toi tu dois le
reconnaître si tu reconnais pas soutenu
jacques dans les boules à chiasso
c'est parti ou alors vous chantez donc à
capella arabian et bien non puisque vous
êtes l'élu cabella absolument tout à
fait allez on y va
il sait partir de cas le slip de bain on
va très très bien de chez un psy
beaucoup oui vous vous allez merci
partie on écoute vous jouez avec nous
chez vous également avec les luca bella
[Musique]
une émission pleine importe quoi et 2008
aurait dû reno et ramaré des tables en
formica
si jamais
ta merci qui n'est pas du cabba il y à
l'épidémie
rama demain
surtout si tu as la forêt chaque côté de
la nationale et attaquent aussi nous car
tu peux payer en toi vois tu peux payer
en trois fois où tu peux payer en trois
fois
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que vous allez trouver de
quelle émission où il parlait puisse
dire mth téléachat télé shopping chez
gagnaire l'udc appelle la place je
trouve que vous avez énormément de
talent j'espère que ça vous plaît chez
vous ce que c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
travail ça c'est des heures et des
heures de répétitions bravo aux l'udc
appelle à aller deuxième chanson après
deux claques sur les couillons ferme la
boutique
j'espère que si les mouvements ne
regarde pas après capitale super
présenté par donneur
là des lavières bruit ont pu même quand
il
l'agencé
par la consommation il y as et
prostituée s'est parlé
économie
ces bruits pour passer d'une famille
safin est toujours comme ça avec des vis
de joie avec des filles de joie avec des
filles de joie
merci à vous merci à vous camille touré
enquête exclamé rssi d'avoir venez nous
voir qualité n'y a pas de problème je
viens quand vous voulez et reprendre -
de chaque bien sûr bien évidemment
[Applaudissements]